wow
wow
my dream is to become a rapper that's my
goal
and i know it's going to go well because
people laugh when i tell them
but i love i love rapping
and so we're blessed here to have one of
the the finest uh dj's in all of hip-hop
mr cypher sounds if we can please
welcome him back to the stage uh with a
round of applause thank you that's what
that means
welcome a pleasure oh and matt matt's
coming as well survive
oh yes that's what that's what i like
okay so um what i love doing is
freestyle rap that's right made up on
the spot based entirely on suggestions
it's not written it's not prepared it's
not rehearsed so for that i need you
guys to get involved i need you guys to
think of what you would like uh or you
know a rap about so everyone here think
of a word a topic or a phrase you'd like
a rap about there are some guidelines
don't come up with like foods and
animals they're the most common most
boring things nothing too unimaginative
don't say stuff that you've heard me
talk about or seen in the room and be
creative right be feel free to be like
you know crazy like the best suggestion
ever was a german man who said a day in
the life of an aztec high priest
it should be fair to him when he said it
it was much politer than that yeah i
can't do a german accent it isn't angry
i feel like that's the fault of their
language rather than me what about
yesterday you had a good one what
happened yesterday uh
um blow jobs for clamshells for climb
chad with someone in a chair over there
that was a good one as well so feel free
to be either german or filthy um but you
can say whatever you want so we'll come
over here what would you lovely people
like a rap about
this is all of your thinking time guys
come on guys
this is anything [ __ ] anything what
okay yeah no that's specific enough that
it bypasses the no food rule smoked
gouda
try to pay attention to the rules guys
and i i appreciate you adding cheese in
case you thought i wasn't cultured
enough to know what gouda was
let's come to you guys over here so for
suggestion number two what would you
like to wrap about
um i feel if we've got cheese that
covers it so let's get
let's get let's get something different
sex wings
sex wings sex wings
oh sex swings
who the [ __ ] eating wings and [ __ ] i
like sex wings
that sound like my kind of girl you got
a sister yeah
don't play with me
i give that bitch's blue cheese
[ __ ] around if you want to
love six weeks
so sex swings and smoked gouda
um let's come to the middle of the room
what would you guys like to wrap about
here jump in anybody come on don't be
shy
first wait whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
crap
made a suggestion that this woman just
went it wasn't me
jesus goes juice yeah you see you said
jews is that correct
what about them okay okay what about
them
something specific yeah something
i feel like we're being quite mean do
you also do you also call them kippers
over here
yeah oh no
no you in the uk they're called referred
to as kippers
that sounds wrong
isn't that the little fish yeah it's a
little fresh as well delicious because
it looks like a little fish apparently i
don't know um no cool so jews the
yarmulkes
let's come to you guys over here what
would you like to rap about
guys you already seen what we're doing
here yeah yeah i feel like they just
they just kind of unplug and disengage
throwing up the momentum come on
anything
yes
yes
thank you
yeah not that stale [ __ ] not that
[ __ ] expired no you've forgotten your
friends no not that chunky milk [ __ ]
wilted and frank leaking in the drawer
fresh [ __ ]
straight on
[Music]
you've had all the thinking time what's
it gonna be
[Applause]
wow so mr richards but for me who was
not here for that give me a brief pressy
real quick i dressed up like a ninja
with my dick out
to surprise my girlfriend
and it didn't go the way i played
he had pressed record on his camera to
make a sense
which immediately made my dick
go away yeah
come on chris yeah dick out ninja
everybody knows what the [ __ ] that means
it was supposed to be chris farley's
next movie
all right you ready i'm i'm so excited
so this as we said a freestyle made up
on the spot based entirely on the
suggestions of smoke gouda sex swings
fresh [ __ ] jews and yarmulkes and dick
out ninja um completely improvised matt
is getting into yeah yeah no that's
perfect um and scythe if you can drop a
beat let's uh enjoy ourselves this is a
fresh beat for you guys it's super
exciting you seem so uncomfortable but
but don't worry you can you you can
trust me
eye contact i know you could trust me
with popping off like a nice with a
fresh [ __ ] oh i feel it get a thrill
open it up like a peel cling film like i
open it up fresh out the package if i
see a [ __ ] so fresh i'll attack it and
i mean in a nice polite way only go
after [ __ ] consensually
and you serve it up you're like oh
steaming hot like a cup of tea and it's
like me a british rapper to compare it a
synonym is coming so naturally
i don't want it dirty but if making eyes
at me and i'm feeling flirty i'll be
like that's okay yes i like i might go
after the [ __ ] with the baby wipe i'm
gonna clean that i'm gonna
[Music]
moving around on the ceiling on my home
had to make sure i had the roof
reinforced why because i got a sex swing
off course using all of the chains ever
so clever momentum on the lever and the
paddle it is leather i can sit on there
and it gets so sweaty fresh [ __ ] on the
six swing getting away when you're over
there i stand still and i just move it
over there time to kill she be rocking
to the front rocking to the back coming
over here it's a little jewish hat i see
a guy and he catch my eyes like yo chris
i'm a nice rabbi i say let me see what
you've got on top of your dome he be
like i got a yamakura i'm like yo bro we
used to call it a kipper in the uk he's
like yo chris what did you say i'm like
apologetic i didn't mean to say it was a
little fish he's like no chris you did a
little jewish diss i apologize he does a
good job teaching all the jewish people
down at the city
it's kind of weird she was shouting out
you like yo chris you can rap about jews
totally fine yeah middle not the finish
i like those jews who can speak that
yiddish they can say schmuck they can be
true there they can go home and eat some
smoke gouda why would they do it what's
the plan you can only get the best out
in
amsterdam in the dutch place i'd be
keeping in touch i'll be getting all the
gooder and sucking it up i'm like this
cheese ain't no joke i love my from
marsh from holland when it is smoked
yeah i don't mean i roll it in the
doobie don't mean i've got it like the
herb yeah to me you were like i'm not
sure this guy believes what i'm talking
about so i'll add on cheese now i
understand yeah i'm waving my finger i
know what cheese is like a dick out
ninja walking in the room
[Music]
my dick's retreating i'm like he doesn't
like you my friend and it disappears
fast like a shuriken
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you